comment vous trouvez ici capitale c'est
vrai qu'on n'est pas sonné que je mieux
chez soi là chaque petit pas exige
beaucoup de patience mais ce travail de
l'infirmière joël jumeaux est essentiel
lorsque le patient reste longtemps
couché là ils paient beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup en muscles et tour dans les
seuils de l'effet plus on les fait
bouger plus s'ils sortent aussi plus
vite là parce que la plupart des
patients souhaitent quitter l'hôpital
notre objectif est de déterminer quels
sont les obstacles à son retour à
domicile quand les passants occupent des
lits mais malheureusement ça engorgent
l'hôpital et tous les services ont un
peu ralenti en ce moment environ 600
patients rétabli reste dans les hôpitaux
alors qu'il devrait être ailleurs
au sus du centre sud de montréal
ils représentent presque 10% des
patients hospitalisés
on a même rouvert une aile fermé pour en
héberger une trentaine
des gens âgés qui ne peuvent plus
retourner chez eux après leur séjour à
l'hôpital il attend à une place dans
ressources intermédiaires ou dans une
résidence pour personnes âgées aux dents
ch et celle des est donc en attendant
on a créé cette unité pour laisser la
place sur les unités actives en médecine
en chirurgie
l'autre solution est que les soignants
se rendent chez les patients bah ça y
est vous la tenez que moi jama soir
s'ils sont les petites yvan côté de vous
dr evelyne gaillard des retraites jeunes
du mont morissette dans sa résidence
pour personnes âgées
ont 20 concours l'ex enseignante a eu la
qu'ovide avant noël l'équipe du celle ci
lui a donné tous ses soins à la
résidence donc il fallu quand même faire
un épisode de soins comme on peut en
voir à l'hôpital faire des prises de
sang ajusté des médicaments pas question
pour elle d'aller à l'hôpital il y avait
beaucoup de monde qui est à peu près de
la place mauvard ailleurs et puis ils
pouvaient pas avoir beaucoup de service
je me suis dis ici je suis bien contente
aussi d'accélérer les congé de l'hôpital
pour les patients comme réjean leduc qui
souffre d'un cancer en phase terminale
êtes vous content d'avoir eu votre
origine chez vous ouais on lui fournit
des bonbonnes d'oxygène
et du personnel comme mélissa leboeuf
est infirmière je veux que tu as
quelqu'un doit bien jouer à nouveau la
fin
on lui évite des allers retours à
l'hôpital et ont préservé ainsi des
ressources pour les chirurgies ici les
soins à domicile c'est la clé pour
désengorger les hôpitaux début de cette
vague de vie de la population et au
début de cette semaine et gris etc c'est
clair que le si les soins à domicile
sont pas davantage déployés on fera ça
c'est évident et pour l'instant ça
permettra probablement en région de
mourir à la maison comme il le souhaite
a promis je vais l'acheter mais avait
janvier j'aime mieux malheur mais quand
ils me voulaient voir de façon humaine
une la médication ici david gêne-t-il et
radio canada montréal